thank you so much VA yes welcome back to
the NBA you were a little winded down
the stretch that's to be expected how
did you cope with that I'm a dog I'm a
dog I put work in day out
[Music]
and I've been putting work in man I
ain't play a game in eight months had a
lot of time you know learned myself a
lot of hard days you know where I went
through it but you know basketball is
you know my life what I love therapeutic
for me and I'm just you know excited to
be back all right walk us through that
last play call 12 I really didn't want
coach to call the timeout that's why I
told them yeah that's the play I wanted
to run right there they believe in me I
actually wanted to go to trip and the
post they told me no so I had to deliver
for them what does this do for your team
we just saw how your teammates responded
to you they're my guys my brothers you
know we put in the work together hard
practices light practices treatment
flights you know we spent a lot of time
together through this process they
helped me out a lot you know with just
saying positive things to me told me to
know you know stay true keep working and
you know it shows right there with them
you know believing in me and it shows
you know how excited everybody is for me
to be back what a return to action
thanks for stopping nice job yes sir hey
happy birthday Ma I'm on the way home
guys